the series of political scandals in
Virginia has reached another top
official the state Senate's Republican
leader acknowledges he was managing
editor of a 1968 college yearbook that
included racist photos and slurs
Virginia's three top elected officials
still face calls to resign over their
past behavior ed O'Keefe is at the
Capitol building in Richmond with more
on this ever changing ever-growing story
good morning to you good morning Gail
today it starts with Governor Northam
who has finally reached out to the two
men behind him in the line of succession
we're told that his phone call with the
Lieutenant Governor justin Fairfax was
very affable House of Delegates Speaker
Kirk Cox the third in line to leave
Virginia responded to questions from
reporters Thursday after the about-face
about blackface by the Governor and
Attorney General and a sexual assault
allegation that's consumed the state's
second in command it's Ben Cox a
Republican would become governor if
Ralph Northam in the next two in line of
succession all Democrats resigned but so
far there's no indication anyone's
leaving Lieutenant Governor Justin
Fairfax facing a 2004 sexual assault
allegation he denies remained in front
of the state Senate Thursday good
evening everyone and Virginia Attorney
General Mark herring wouldn't comment
last night on his admitted experience
wearing blackface while Governor Northam
well good afternoon has not appeared in
public since a controversial press
conference on Saturday I was not aware
and now a fourth elected officials Tommy
Norment the top Republican in Virginia
state Senate and managing editor of his
1968 senior yearbook at Virginia
Military Institute denied he knew
anything about these photos of students
in blackface or racial slurs including
the n-word that appear in the yearbook
you can go through that year
one racial slur attributed to me you
won't find any photograph that I am in
that is disrespectful
last night Virginia's legislative Black
Caucus and congressional delegation
called on governor Northam to resign but
in separate statements they stopped
short of saying the same about the
Lieutenant Governor and Attorney General
saying that they will continue to
reserve judgment wait and see how this
all plays out normal all right ed thank
you